madame la ministre lundi dernier la
centrale nucléaire de fessenheim
c'est arrêter l'énergie nucléaire dans
cette centrale est emblématique a permis
aux français de bénéficier d'une
électricité deux fois moins cher qu'en
allemagne elle a permis à la france de
n'émettre qu'un pour cent des émissions
mondiales de co2 la plaçant très loin
devant son voisin allemand
elle a enfin fortement bénéficié à
l'emploi et à la trique à l'attractivité
de la région alsacienne
la décision de monsieur hollande que
vous mettez en oeuvre aujourd'hui ce
sont près de 2000 emplois locaux qui
vont disparaître sans aucune
concrétisation du plan de reconversion
promis par l'état ce sont 400 millions
d'euros d'indemnités que l'état devra
verser à edf comme l'a cruellement
rappelé la cour des comptes dans un
rapport particulièrement sévère ce sont
six à dix millions de tonnes de co2
supplémentaires par an le repli vers
l'éolien et le solaire ne pouvant
conduire qu'à importer davantage
d'énergies carbonées cet enfant l'exact
inverse de ce que recommande le giec
dans ses derniers rapports qui inclut
quel que soit le scénario retenu une
part significative de nucléaire
madame la ministre la décision que vous
avez prise aura des conséquences
particulièrement négative cette décision
n'est pas économique
la facture énergétique des français et
des entreprises françaises vin va
largement progressé elle n'est pas
social vous pénalisez très fortement
tout un bassin d'emploi et elle n'est
évidemment pas écologique vous priver
notre pays d'une énergie décarbonée et
c'est visiblement un avis partagé par
monsieur le ministre ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire alors madame
la ministre pouvait vont donc nous dire
ce qui a vraiment motivé ce choix pour
vous répondre la parole et le cas madame
la ministre de la transition écologique
et solidaire madame elisabeth bornes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
présidente
l'arrêt de fessenheim incarne l'écologie
de responsabilité porté par le président
de la république le gouvernement et la
majorité depuis 2010 est avec cette
décision nous tenons
nous promesses nous transformons en
profondeur notre modèle énergétique et
nous accompagnons les français et les
territoires dans cette transformation
avec l'arrêt des deux réacteurs de
fessenheim nous engageons la réduction à
50% de la part du nucléaire d'ici 2035
tout en développement massivement les
énergies renouvelables pourquoi parce
qu'un système électrique plus
diversifiée est un système plus
résilients et c'est pour ça que nous
allons multiplier par deux la part de
l'éolien et parfums que la part du
photovoltaïque dans les dix ans mais
dans le même temps le gouvernement et
particulièrement vigilant à
l'accompagnement des salariés et des
territoires
s'agissant des salariés d'edf ils seront
tous reclassés au sein du groupe
et s'agissant des salariés des sous
traitants une cellule de reclassement
est en place pour les accompagner
concernant la reconversion du territoire
35 millions d'euros ont déjà été engagés
et il est vrai que la crise a conduit à
prendre du retard dans les mises en
place des différents dispositifs
mais je voudrais souligner l'annoncé
récente du d'un projet d'implantation
d'une usine de biocombustibles qui
pourrait générer 700 emplois dans le
territoire donc soyez assurés madame la
sénatrice que notre politique
énergétique s'inscrit pleinement dans le
respect des accords de paris de l'accord
de paris et que nous accompagnons les
français et les territoires dans la
transition à la présidente quelques
secondes
oui madame la ministre vous l'avez dit
c'est un c'est un choix qui est un choix
politiciens et idéologiques et nous
attendons vraiment que l'état déploie
une stratégie qui puisse être à la
hauteur du défi posé par l'arrêt des
réacteurs nucléaires et à cet égard je
regrette que le gouvernement ait refusé
la feuille de route que le sénat
proposait dans le cadre de l'examen de
la loi énergie climat qui visait à
suivre les démantèlements à venir comme
je regrette que l' ordonnance relative à
l'accompagnement des fermetures des
centrales à charbon
prévu aussi par cette loi n'est pas été
publiés après neuf mois de travaux
la convention citoyenne pour le climat a
présenté ses travaux
riche de nombreuses propositions c'est
bien ce qu'a souligné le président de la
république aux 150 citoyennes et
citoyens réunis avant-hier à l'elysée
cet exercice de grande ampleur inédite a
été largement salué un travail collectif
de réflexion de délibération qui
participe de ce nouvel élan démocratique
dans notre pays a tant besoin
l'abstention est le même inédite de
dimanche dernier nous le rappelle si
besoin leurs préconisations touche à
tous les domaines de notre vie
quotidienne
promouvoir une alimentation saine et
durable et pas plus tard qu est ce qu
hier soir dans cet hémicycle nous en
débattions en séance publique mais aussi
développer les transports propres
rénover les bâtiments investir dans
l'industrie les cakes nologie de demain
les énergies décarbonées les réseaux et
la préservation de nos ressources à nos
15 milliards d'euros en plus d'ici à
2022 ont d'ailleurs été annoncée pour
réussir cette transition et énergétique
la quasi-totalité des mesures adoptées
par la convention devrait être prise et
trouver une traduction réglementaire
lorsque cela est possible mais aussi
législatives puis référendaire le
président la république a également
rappelé hier que le plan de relance
européen devait être nécessairement
conditionnées à des engagements
climatiques de la part des états membres
c'est donc un agenda national et
européen
résolument tournée vers l'environnement
et sa préservation qui suscite de fortes
attentes alors pourriez vous nous
préciser madame la ministre
l'agenda des travaux qui viendront
mettre en oeuvre cette expression
citoyenne et je pense plus
particulièrement à l'agenda législatif
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
la ministre de la transition écologique
et solidaire
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice cartron
alors effectivement le président de la
république s'est exprimé lundi sur les
suites données aux travaux des 150
citoyens qui ont donné de leur temps
personnel pour faire des propositions
fortes pour le climat et je pense que
cela mérite le respect il a fixé un cap
clair et ambitieux et montré que nous
irons au bout de la transformation
écologique de notre pays
d'abord en étant au rendez vous des
attentes de la convention dont il a
repris la quasi totalité des
propositions 146 sur 149 ensuite en
donnant un calendrier précis pour que
ces propositions se transforme en action
donc d'ici la fin du mois un conseil de
défense écologique assurera la mise en
oeuvre des mesures qui relèvent du
gouvernement des plans de relance 15
milliards d'euros supplémentaires vont
être consacrés à la transition
écologique
enfin un projet de loi sera présenté à
la rentrée pour les mesures qui relèvent
du niveau législatif
ce projet de loi nous allons le
construire en concertation avec les élus
les parlementaires et les citoyens de la
convention mon ministère et l'ensemble
du gouvernement est pleinement mobilisée
dans ce sens et comme vous l'avez
rappelé agir au niveau européen est
aussi essentiel c'est pourquoi le
président de la république porte une
reconstruction économique écologique et
solidaire au plan national comme au plan
européen et les propositions de la
convention citoyenne sont au coeur de ce
projet le président de la république a
pris acte des propositions formulées par
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
j'irai dans un cérémonial quasi
monarchique
et comment at on pu passer d'un exercice
de participation directe à une telle
incarnation du pouvoir et de la décision
politique mais sur le fond et c'est le
plus important
le rejet a priori de la proposition d'un
prélèvement annuel à hauteur de 4 % sur
les dividendes des grosses entreprises
envoient un message politique très
claire on touchera au portefeuille de
ceux qui ont le plus de moyens
et pourtant le mouvement des gilet jaune
nous l'a bien montré aucune justice
environnementale ne sera possible sans
justice sociale et donc sans justice
fiscale et refusé un prélèvement de 4 %
des dividendes c'est se priver de deux
milliards d'euros par an et c'est la
cohérence de l'ensemble des 149
proposition qui est remise en cause
condamnant cet exercice à excusez moi
mais une simple opération de
communication est malheureusement dfa
sans lendemain donc monsieur le ministre
pourquoi un tel rejet pour vous répondre
la parole est à vous monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur bruno le maire vous avez la
parole oui monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
ce sénateur pour une raison simple c'est
que nous avons déjà fait d'erreur une
fois que nous avons été condamné aussi
bien au niveau national qu'au niveau
européen et qui devait fallu ensuite
récupérer le montant de cette taxe qui
était jugée comme contraire à l'égalité
devant l'impôt et que j'ai été obligé de
présenter devant vous une surtaxe à
l'impôt sur les sociétés de 3% pour
récupérer le montant de cette taxe sur
les dividendes qui avaient été jugées
illégales
nous avons fait l'erreur une fois ne
refaisons pas l'erreur deux fois en
revanche qu'il faille plus de justice
fiscale mais j'en suis le premier
convaincu qu'il fase et une fiscalité
plus verte et nous sommes tout à fait
prêts à le faire dans le cadre du plan
de relance
mais si vous voulez une fiscalité plus
juste aidez moi monsieur le sénateur je
sais que votre groupe y est prêt à
mettre en place une taxation digitales
non seulement au niveau national mais
aussi au niveau européen voulait
chercher la richesse là où elle se
trouve
ce sont les géants du numérique mondiaux
qui ont fait les plus grands profits
pendant cette crise économique c'est eux
qu'il faut les taxer
et c'est cette taxation digital qui sera
juste voulu une taxation verte mais
aidez nous à mettre en place une
taxation carbone aux frontières de
l'union européenne
parce que rien ne sert de décarbonés
notre industrie en phr
si nous sommes pas capables de récupérer
à l'entrée de nos frontières
la taxation carbone des produits
importés de l'extérieur
vous voulez une taxation plus juste mais
aidez nous à mettre en place au niveau
européen
la taxation sur les transactions
financières qui existent en france mais
qui n'existe pas au niveau européen
étendons cette taxe sur les transactions
financières au niveau européen plutôt
que de le faire au niveau national et
enfin voulait une taxation juste mais
des mois lutter contre l'évasion fiscale
et contre l'optimisation fiscale en
mettant en place une taxation minimale à
l'impôt sur les sociétés
comme nous nous battons pour le faire au
niveau international et que nous
arrivons à le faire avec l'allemagne
vous voyez il ya beaucoup de chantiers à
mettre en oeuvre pour avoir une
fiscalité plus juste au niveau
international comme au niveau national
mais je ne pense pas que ce soit en
renouvelant les erreurs du passé
c'est plutôt en inventant la fiscalité
du futur pour vous répondre
non pas pour vous répondre mais heureux
monsieur savoldelli oui merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre je
comprends bien la difficulté qu est la
vôtre
mais enfin reproché aux élus communistes
écologie citoyens de pas est à vos côtés
dans l'évasion fiscale c'est un manque
de sérieux
franchement c'est un manque de sérieux
ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose monsieur le ministre
vous et sourire mais l'opinion publique
elle sourit pas on peut pas dire baker a
balayé d'un revers de main il serait
impossible de toucher à 4% les
dividendes
quand on regarde que si dix dernières
années la hausse des dividendes à
augmenter mes chers collègues de 70%
vous connaissez vous quelqu'un un
salarié un paysan vous connaissez
quelqu'un qui a eu 70 % d'augmentation
ces dix dernières années donc
franchement c'est pas sérieux
et à chaque fois qu'on vous fait des
propositions que ça soit d'ordre social
ou dordonne vironnement talent on vous
pose la question de répartir qui est un
effort fiscal des plus riches c'est tout
le temps non donc ce que vous êtes en
train de faire c'est une opération de
communication avec du capitalisme vert
et là je vous le dis je vous le dis au
gouvernement je pourrais m'adresser au
président de la république
vous êtes sur un populisme il faut
conclure extrêmement dangereux
extrêmement dangereux
merci la parole est à notre collègue
laurence rossignol pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres
chers collègues et de droite et de
gauche s'étaient le mantra du candidat
macron en 2017
le candidat devenu président les
français ont vite constaté qu'en réalité
votre gouvernement s'inspire est plutôt
d'une dit de gauche ni de gauche
jusqu'au premier et le deuxième tour des
élections municipales ou clairement
c'était et de droite et de droite
tout ça a pu sembler un peu confus aux
français tout ça peut sembler un peu
confus au français mais en revanche le
message qui vous a été envoyé dimanche
dernier est assez clair ceni en marche
ni en marche
car même si les élections intermédiaires
sont souvent difficile pour les
gouvernements en place celle de 2020
sont une cuve est assez spectaculaire
à quelques exceptions près et pas des
moins des gens profitent monsieur le
premier ministre pour saluer une manière
républicaine
votre élection au havre d'autant plus
que la dimension personnelle de cette
élection est probablement importante
donc à quelques étés sont prêts la
majorité ne conquiert aucune ville
importante et même mêmes pères des
villes qu'elle avait obtenu auparavant
grâce à des transfuges souvent
d'ailleurs de nos propres rangs je pense
à lyon je pense à besançon
je pense à strasbourg et même dans mon
département c'est arrivé et sans parler
bien sûr des échecs de vos ministres qui
comptait bien faire main basse sur la
ville de paris et qui chacun sait ont
aussi échoué et le taux d'abstention
inédit malgré vos promesses de
réconcilier les français la démocratie
ne relativise pas pour autant la clarté
du message qui était adressé au
président de la république et à sa
majorité
monsieur le premier ministre en campagne
aux arbres vous
diot havrais que vous reviendriez en
2022 ma question est simple souhaitez
vous continuer à diriger la france et
avec quelles orientations politiques
pour vous répondre la parole des toques
ministre en charge des relations avec le
parlement
je marque vdo merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
j'avais l'air déçu d'abord d'abord je
voudrais saluer toutes celles et ceux
qui ont décidé au saut à ces élections
municipales comme à toutes les élections
de défendre leurs idées parce que y'a
rien de plus sain et plus honorable en
démocratie que de défendre ses idées je
pense qu'on devrait saluer toutes celles
et ceux qui ont fait le choix de
s'engager ceux qui ont gagné et puis se
trompent ardue parce que ça fait partie
de la clé démocratie que de gagner ou de
perdre la deuxième chose qui devrait
nous alerter
vous avez assez peu parlé cette chose
c'est la question de l'abstention je
pense qu'à nous aident vrai ça n'était
pas la partie la plus longue
c'est une question qui est importante
pour nous de voir au fond on sait que le
mandat de maire et sur l'a8 le maire et
celui sans doute l'élu le plus aimé et
dans cette élection c'est l'élection il
ya eu plus d'abstention et je pense que
ça doit nous interroger
la troisième chose vous avez l'air de
vouloir en faire un test national or si
c'est un test national j'aurais salué
les victoires de géra darmana à
tourcoing et d'edouard philippe au havre
je n'ose parler de ma propre élection
dans ma commune
messi soit c'est un test national soit
c'est une élection locale et l'équation
personnelle compte d'ailleurs vous
l'avez dit vous-même
auquel cas faisons plutôt une école une
élection locale
la troisième chose que je voudrais vous
dire les élections par part comment
dirais-je habitudes et et expériences
s'invite à la fois à la modestie à la
lucidité
vous avez comme moi gagné et perdu des
élections vous avez perdu des élections
97 en 2002 et en 2007
moi aussi j'ai perdu des élections
locales nous avons perdu des élections
nationales
vous aussi et moi aussi donc ça devrait
nous inviter à la modestie parce que
parfois ce qui paraît des victoires n'en
ai pas et parfois quand on perd on n'a
pas les et la nécessité de lucidité dont
je pense qu'il faut faire ce travail de
lucidité puis la troisième chose que je
voudrais vous dire madame la sénatrice
il ya des résultats il ya des résultats
variables d'un département à l'autre
parce que l'équation locale a compté
vous savez comme moi la seule chose est
la seule exigence qu'on doit avoir
parce que c'est l'engagement que nous
avons tous comme élus nationaux locaux
cette pré faire prévaloir les et
l'intérêt national
l'intérêt local et au fond maintenant il
ya des élus on doit s'en féliciter c'est
avec eux qu'on doit travailler pour
faire en sorte qu on fasse avancer le
pays mieux nombreux et nous pourrons les
relever ensemble la semaine dernière un
journal révélait que pendant plusieurs
années les portables des avocats de
renom ont été surveillés dans le cadre
d'une enquête préliminaire ordonnée par
le parquet national financiers cette
enquête décidée pour une prétendue
violation du secret professionnel a été
ordonné alors que quelques jours avant
une information judiciaire avait été
ouverte le 26 février 2014 sur des faits
connexes
malgré l'absence de preuves le pnf a
relancé cette enquête en octobre 2016
sans succès non plus en décembre 2019
un classement sans suite pour infraction
insuffisamment caractérisée et même
prononcé les conditions de cette enquête
sont troublantes
enda presse étaient jointes au reste de
la procédure pendant longtemps et ces
résultats ont été caché à la défense le
pnf agit comme une juridiction
d'exception qui nous rappellent les
pires errements du justice livrée à
elle-même l'autorité judiciaire ne
saurait être hors contrôle
veiller à l'intégrité des comptes
publics ou privés est une chose régler
des comptes avec les hommes politiques
en est une autre
la cour rend d arrêt et non pas des
services disait un grand magistrat du
19e siècle
cette imbrication malsaine du bnf dans
le jeu politique nous a même valu il y a
trois ans une élection présidentielle
insolite où le favori n'a même pas été
qualifié pour le second tour
à la suite de propos tenus par l'ancien
procureur du bnf
le président de la république a saisi le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
et vous madame avait demandé timidement
un rapport circonstancié sur la nature
précise de l'enquète du pmf il était
temps de saisir l'inspection générale
tout à l'heure de la justice car c'est
l'existence même du plf qui pose
problème
madame la garde des sceaux quand on dit
vous faire face à cette crise de
confiance de la justice après que le mur
deco ne soit pas suivie par le mur de la
honte
[Applaudissements]
on veut répandre la parole et à madame
le garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur charron
je comprends l'émotion qu'a suscitée les
propos de madame mais ou let lorsqu'elle
a répondu à la commission denquête
devant l'assemblée nationale
et vous l'avez rappelez-vous mail le
président de la république est le garant
de l'indépendance de l'autorité
judiciaire a sollicité un avis du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
j'ai partagé vraiment les mois de et les
interrogations liées aux révélations
faites par l'hebdomadaire le point et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
demandé non pas timidement j'ai demandé
un rapport madame la procureure générale
de paris qui me l'a rendu hier soir au
vu de ce rapport
j'ai donc immédiatement décidé de saisir
l'inspection générale de la justice afin
que l'inspection puisse déterminer
l'étendue et la proportionnalité des
actes d'investigation ainsi que le cadre
procédural de l'enquète qui a été
effectué pour autant monsieur le
sénateur je crois qu'il est important de
ne pas faire d'amalgamé je voudrais de
ce point de vue simplement redire trois
choses s'il ya des dysfonctionnements
qui sont révélés par l'inspection
générale de la justice il faudra aller
reconnaître
pour autant je crois que le parquet
national financier est une institution
qui est la garante de la souveraineté
judiciaire de notre pays et nous le
voyons dans des dossiers tels que hsbc
tels que google os et dans ce cadre là
le pnf a vraiment montrer sa
reconnaissance internationale son
expertises sa compétence je dirai
ensuite c'est le deuxième point que dans
aucune affaire
le gouvernement n'a donné d'instruction
individuelle a aucun magistrat
et c'est important à redire parce que
c'est le gage de la confiance que les
français doivent avoir dans la justice
nous donnons les instructions générales
parce que c'est la structuration et
hiérarchique du parquet à la française
qui
nous y autorise mais pas d'instruction
individuelle est ma troisième
observation sera pour dire que des
réponses adaptées à ces situations
seront apportées par ce qui donc
l'essentiel de ne pas laisser le doute
s'installer
parce que j'ai confiance comme vous dans
la justice française monsieur charon
vous avez quelques secondes
la parole est notre collègue jean luc
fichet pour le gym judo en vigueur ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre le président de la république
recevait lundi les 150 membres de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
notre groupe qui a salué la qualité des
travaux menés par ce panel de citoyens
qui se sont engagés en faveur d'une
transition écologique ambitieuse pour
notre pays le chef de l'état indiqué
reprendre 146e des 149 propositions
formulées en voulant je cite les
transmette son filtre au parlement où ce
qui relève de la loi un texte multi
mesure est ainsi annoncée pour la
rentrée nous aurions besoin
d'éclaircissements sur ce point surtout
de l'assurance qui sera bien accompagné
des financements nécessaires sur le
court terme et pas seulement dans un
cadre pluriannuel sur le sujet par
exemple de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation durable qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur des enjeux
économiques sont en effet indissociable
des enjeux environnementaux
il faut renforcer la lutte contre les
inégalités sociales face à
l'alimentation et les agriculteurs
doivent être accompagnés dans la
transition agro écologiques en termes
d'aidé financière mais aussi de
formation sans un engagement résolu de
l'état en la matière les propositions
formulées risque sinon de rester lettre
morte
il faut maintenir des usines partout sur
le territoire ne pas concentrer celle ci
dans les métropoles les mieux desservis
je cite le président l'aqueduc le 29
juin lors de la convention citoyenne
parallèlement ou en même temps à morlaix
dans le finistère
air france hop informe de la fermeture
du site de maintenance aéronautique de
276 emploi monsieur le premier ministre
comment pouvez vous agir et il est
encore temps pour éviter un tel désastre
dans des territoires en difficulté et
être véritablement en cohérence avec les
engagements de la convention citoyenne
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et à madame la ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur alors comme vous
l'avez dit le président de la république
a reçu lundi les 150 citoyens et il a
été au rendez vous des propositions de
la convention en reprenant la
quasi-totalité 146 sur 149 des
propositions de la convention
au-delà de cet engagement ce sont bien
sûr des calendrier précis qui ont été
annoncées par le président de la
république avec à la fois un conseil de
défense écologie d'ici la fin du mois
prendre les mesures qui relèvent du
niveau réglementaire donc du
gouvernement s'est aussi 15 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires pour accélérer
la transition écologique qui seront
intégrées dans le plan de relance et je
pense que ça vaut répond je l'espère à
votre question
effectivement cette transition
écologique elle mérite des soutiens
financiers
que ce soit pour accélérer la transition
du modèle agricole pour accélérer la
rénovation des passoires thermiques et
des bâtiments que ce soit pour accélérer
les investissements dans le transport
ferroviaire ces investissements ils
seront nécessaires et ses 15 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires
mais ils seront bien intégré au plan de
relance et puis au delà un projet de loi
effectivement spécifique sera présenté à
la rentrée un projet de loi que nous
allons naturellement élaboré en
concertation avec les élus avec les
parlementaires avec les citoyens bien
entendu et je partage ce que vous dite
évidemment cette transition écologique
elle entraîne des transformations
profondes dans les territoires cette
transition écologique elle doit
embarquer l'ensemble des français
l'ensemble des territoires
et c'est bien le sens de la transition
écologique et solidaire que nous voulons
mener le sommet g5 celle qui s'est tenue
hier à nouakchott s'inscrit dans la
suite du sommet de pau voulu il ya six
mois par le président de la république
pour refonder notre action au sahel
cette rencontre avait permis d'établir
deux objectifs pour gagner cette guerre
d'abord combattre les terroristes
ensuite former et équiper les armées
nationales
n'oublions jamais que chaque jour nos
soldats livre un âpre combat contre les
djihadistes dans le sahel 41 militaires
français y ont fait le sacrifice de leur
vie depuis 2013
depuis pau des succès spectaculaires ont
été atteints par nos forces armées
ils font notre fierté et notre groupe
veut leur témoigner toute notre
gratitude la mobilisation européenne à
nos côtés se confirme même si elle reste
encore trop lente
la task force takouba est à cet égard
aussi importante que représentative
madame la ministre
l'estonie sera-t-il le seul pays
européen à nous rejoindre mais après
avoir gagné la guerre le plus dur est
souvent de gagner la paix vous l'avez
dit vous-même madame la ministre
une opération tactique bar cannes n'a
pas vocation à être pérenne
l'action militaire n'est pas une fin en
soi mais un moyen au service d'un
objectif global qui a motivé notre
présence permettre à des états de
demeurer libre et de fonctionner
normalement de manière indépendante au
service de leur population
c'est pourquoi deux objectifs avaient
été fixés à pau pour gagner la paix le
retour des états dans les territoires
ravagé par le djihadisme l'aide au
développement de la région cependant le
président de la république la nuit lui
même à son arrivée à nouakchott
hier il faut en faire davantage dans ce
domaine ma question est donc simple où
on l alliance à elle et sommes nous sur
la bonne voie je vous remercie
mais pour vous répondre la parole et à
madame le ministre désormais madame
florence parly vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur au sahel nous avons trois mots
d'ordre
le premier c'est la détermination
second c'est la coopération et le
troisième c'est la complémentarité
alors oui nous sommes déterminés à
continuer à lutter contre le terrorisme
dans cette région
et c'est grâce à la détermination du
président de la république qui en
lançant le sommet de pau a créé cet élan
qui nous a permis tous ensemble de
rencontres de remporter et d'engranger
des succès notamment militaire et de
donner un nouvel élan à notre action ce
nouvel élan s'est en effet celui de la
coopération car au sahel la victoire est
possible si nous restons unis et sous ni
si nous unissons nos forces avec les
pays du g5 sahel et aussi avec les
européens
il faut le faire pour accompagner au
combat les forces armées locales les
forces armées chiliennes se sont
remobilisés c'est visible des camps
militaires ont été repris et le niveau
de coopération s'est grandement
améliorée vous l'avez souligné la task
force takouba va pouvoir démarrer dans
quelques jours avec des forces spéciales
françaises estonienne dans un premier
temps qui seront rejointes par des
forces spéciales tchèque puis suédoise
peut-être italienne les grecs également
sont en train d'examiner la question de
leur participation et je voudrais quand
même souligner une chose c'est que en
général les processus européen sont
lents et bien en moins d'un an ce sont
treize pays dont onze européens qui
auront contribué à construire cette
force
enfin dernière condition de succès c'est
la complémentarité et là c'est vrai
l'action militaire n'est pas une fin en
soi il faut pouvoir aider les pays du
sahel à faire face à ces défis
sécuritaires économiques et sociaux et
c'est pourquoi sur le terrain les
militaires de barkan contribuer à
accompagner le retour de l'état comme
ils l'ont fait encore récemment à la bge
en ga et oui les populations reviennent
alors bien sûr il faudra faire plus mais
les premiers signaux sont là nous sommes
dans la bonne voie